[Music]
mashed potatoes there you go
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
giving fans a look inside their 2018
wedding and their Whirlwind first dance
I just really wanted the music to be fun
even our first dance song of a thousand
dances a thousands I'll always get it
wrong the couple opens up about their
ideas in a new teaser trailer for volume
2 of their Netflix docu-series Harry and
Megan and honestly it looks Epic
two three
[Music]
yeah the lovebirds shared snaps from
their first dance as husband and wife
said to Wilson Pickett's track Land of
1000 Dances and yes yes that is Elton
John I think they're so happy I know
they're so happy that was our first
dance it was so fun it was just spinning
like a whirlwind it was so great there
was an impromptu dance of James Corden
managed to get Charles William and Harry
up on the dance floor and George Clooney
summoned both Megan and Kate to a bit of
a boogie on the dance floor so quite
unexpected when it comes to a royal
wedding of course this teaser comes just
days after volume 1 dropped causing a
stir Stateside and across the pond I
think most people over here are thinking
you left Britain because you didn't want
the glare of the media and yet here you
are courting the biggest streaming Giant
on the planet you want to have your cake
and eat it critics slammed the couple
for stepping into the spotlight with
their new show after leaving the
high-profile royal family this is a
couple we've been so fiercely protective
of their privacy and yet here they are
invading their own privacy by putting
those very private lives right in
everyone's living room following its
release the Duke and Duchess of sussex's
global press secretary addressed all the
chatter in a statement to ET writing
that the couple never cited privacy as
the reason for stepping back from their
Royal duties before calling it a
distorted narrative that was intended to
trap the couple into silence the
statement continues noting that when
Harry and Meg announce their decision
they actually doubled down on their
desire to continue their roles and
public duties and now they are choosing
to share their story on their terms I
realized they're never going to protect
you
I was terrified I didn't want a history
to repeat itself
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth meanwhile the
royal family has yet to speak out about
the docu-series
I've spoken to senior Palisade who said
they are reluctant to comment unless
there is anything damaging
untrue or defamatory in this docu-series
they really don't want to be drawn into
it but it's a case of keep calm and
carry on and let's not get too
distracted by this
[Music]